and tell me this superhero movie
obviously stunts a go-go
so did you do many of the stunts
yourselves
she does um quite a lot she likes being
in a harness i mean it's wonderful to
watch her
me not so much i love uh the stunt woman
i love her i thought
maybe you were gonna like it more
because i was like oh she hasn't done
this before
and you know i i want to be 20 feet up
and like
spun around like a propeller and then
octavia literally we had her in her
harness the first day
her toes were not off the ground yet
like she's literally still touching the
ground and she was like oh oh oh oh oh
you're still on the ground she's like
not for me not for me
because in jersey studs like nick what
happened in intelligence you're a sitcom
like you're a computer geek so
presumably any stunt work you can do
oh you think so um i i had to fall off a
chair
and they got a stunt person in to do it
and it was so lame
it was so lame and i was desperate to do
it but they just were like no no we've
got to get someone in to do it
and there was a bit where i had to look
as if i'd been tasered and i think i did
it for some of the close-up but
for most of it they're like no we'll get
a stunt person to do and i think it's
probably because my accent was
so bad it wouldn't work it's work for
people because
frank wasn't what's the story with you
and david bedeal you did a fight scene
well david padilla and i had to do a
scene where he hit me on the head with a
big
monkey wrench and i arrived expecting
this
robber monkey wrench but they just had a
normal
heavy piece of iron and they said it's
fine dave's going to
swing you and he'll stop about four
inches from your head i
love david we were in you know we've
been in a double act we we live in the
same road still he's like a brother to
me but i know he's incapable
of those kind of motor skills
and i said if we do this he's going to
hit me on the head
and they all went and he and he got
quite upset and said you're making me
sound
you know stupid and i felt bad and i
said okay we'll do it and we did it
take one he smacked me across there
the pain of that knock on the head
was i must say helped by the joy
of having been so correct
[Applause]
[Music]